The third question asked, what is the maximum possible path length in B?
It's pretty straightforward to see the chains have a maximum possible path length of n-1
and this n-1 is an upper bound on the path link of any graph with n nodes
and so we are checking to see if we can make B into a chain.
If we can, then n-1 will be the maximum possible path link
and this is about as close as we can get into making B into a chain.
In fact, it doesn't matter how many nodes are on the left side. We can still only get a chain of six.
For another node on the right side, we can make our chain to it as longer, and so the maximum
possible path link in a bipartite graph depends on the number of nodes in the smallest group,
and so in general the maximum possible path link in a bipartite graph is the minimum
of 2 times the number of nodes in the left group or 2 times the number of nodes in the right group
or the number of nodes in total minus 1.
For B, we get that the possible maximum path link is six edges.